what is happening there citizens of the reject
Nation we are here to watch two new trailers for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania you know how we
do when our movies coming around the corner ladies
and gentlemen leave a like for John that's the
only reason you'll leave a like so you better go
ahead and do it right John that's right you like
me you really like me also guys I will not stop
plugging these shirts until the movie's on and
maybe even after depending on the reception of
the film Citizen Kane shirts people real rejects
exclusive I want to thank everyone who has already
bought themselves a shirt from shopzeroedition.com
because it's one of the best ways to support the
channel and it's just b-i-t-c-h-i-n I forget the
YouTube rules about swear words in the beginning
of a video I love wearing them get compliments
on them at the gym and I go I don't know like
what I'm like just go away go away don't talk
to me anymore vocal cords hate when hot women
at the gym talk to me it's really uncomfortable
alrighty let's get to it guys oh we're gonna
watch uh the new Dynasty spot and the featurette
drop them in a final cut I think the featurettes
first but we're just gonna watch it in one
go then we'll talk about whatever's in here
we always love doing the unexpected with Scott
Lang Batman is arguably the character that is
the most underestimated and underrated a key to
saving the universe in Avengers end game yeah
so carrying that tradition we thought well
let's use this film to kick off phase five
that's really cool in almost a decade now that
I've been playing this part I've loved it and
I feel protective of Scott Lang and Ant-Man
it's really nice coming back I still kind of
can't believe that I'm sitting there and
it's like wow there's Michelle Pfeiffer
and there's Michael Douglas I just saved
eight bucks gotta admire you that's not to
get used to working with Legends sure you're
sending a signal down to the quantum Realm
where wow the quantum realm Universe
beneath ours Janet has been very quiet
about her time in the quantum realm
maybe would have made different choices
cool Jesus isn't what you think different
choices with Kang it's terrifying and if
there ever was a maniac loose in the quantum
realm it's him playing Kang the Conqueror is
such a gift your reality you're holding on to
I know how it is this is the beginning and he
cannot be contained he's the beginning and the
end that shot man always gets something like this
which is so transportive and visually striking
people should really see it in a movie theater
yes you want it to be as big and as visceral
and consuming as possible audiences are going
to watch this and go I can't believe this is
happening it's going to be Bonkers I hope I
have that response we're camping we've never
been camping but we've always talked about it
that's what he's fighting for to go
camping Scotland you're an Avenger oh
you have a daughter but you've lost
a lot of time she's a troublemaker
I'm the man who can give you time
Scott you cannot trust him I just lost
so much he can give us a second chance
ooh good trailer he will bring
me what I need everything you
call a life will end you've may not
want her to watch this I had a deal
you thought you could win I don't have to win we
both just have to lose sorry Cassie that man in
the WASP Quantum yeah it's like overwhelming
oh my goodness gorgeous and glorious is how
I feel when watching that trailer both of those
trailers you know I feel like these featurettes
sometimes just don't get enough respect and
they often do a good job of reminding me of
where we're coming from because you know looking
back on uh the first Ant-Man film and even the
second especially the second one the way that
was received a film that I was like I actually
quite enjoyed this one but I got I got a lot
of crap the place where it was slotted to have
this be the kick off for phase five and for
ant-man's its third film a movie The ironic
sense of like this the tiniest character in all
of the MCU to get one of this this like massive
debut and to be part of like this massive
Trilogy on an endnote because I've always
been sort of on the smaller side now they're
gonna be even smaller but also even bigger but
you know what I mean guys I've always been a
little bit more on on the less scale side you
know like sometimes consequential sometimes we're
slotted in between films that had like the biggest
Stakes ever and then they get a film that's not
that big mistakes comparatively to what we just
saw so to get a movie where it's going to be uh
an introduction and a definition for what phase
five is going to ultimately uh amount to and to
have King the Conqueror be introduced in here I
think that's just so cool for for this specific
franchise because especially with Ant-Man when
you look at it they've had the same cast other
than Michelle Pfeiffer came in the second one
and then Cassie Langston but they've had the same
main core players and the director uh from the
beginning you know if you exclude the whole
thing yes but but they've had the same thing
essential Parts yeah I'm talking Evangeline Lily
and Michael Douglas is all right and and uh what
is his name it's not Scott Derrickson who's the
guy who directed this movie and to have Peyton
Reed uh helming it and to have this journey
I feel like ant-man's earned it uh to be here
and yeah and I and the second trailer too was
great because it it focused I said a lot John
you you say some stuff yeah I I liked that they
highlighted it I think what one thing that hasn't
really fully hit me but I think is really cool
is here they highlighted how like Scott Lang was
crucial instrumental in the outcome of end game
which is like the Pinnacle and we're going into
phase five it's been a whole phase since then
but two this does feel like very consequential
and like there is something culminating here
and so to have this sort of uh opposite bookend
with Scott Lang yeah helping through the quantum
realm save everybody's bacon on the last Go Round
And now here he's going into the quantum realm
to potentially you know we'll see how it goes
but maybe make the ultimate sacrifice and maybe a
similarly heroic thing but with an opposite kind
of an outcome or a heavier sort of outcome and so
yeah like I think it's a nice full circle moment
for uh the character and two I mean yeah I think
we both are sort of in the minority of people who
both really liked Ant-Man and the wasp and the
first one too I've always found very charming
and here this feels like yeah this is going to be
the one that elevates the character to a bigger
caliber in terms of the weight and the impact
because I mean looking at the full second trailer
and then this TV spot I just love the amount of
like intensity and stakes and I think for this
character that's a cool thing because that's not
been what they've LED with up until now so not
only do we get sort of a Twist on the tone in you
know the micro Universe of just Ant-Man but also
now yeah this big important contribution to the
you know entirety of phase five and six to come
yeah with the scope and the scale to have it be on
this visually daring and psychedelic of a level I
think is really cool it feels natural for Ant-Man
at the same time because you know we've teased
the quantum realm via through Ant-Man yeah even
with endgame that's how we get there so to have
it be like all within here it doesn't feel like
an unnatural transition to suddenly do something
this high stakes and this High Caliber this High
concept of visuals because it's been leading to
this the entire time and I think it's really neat
it's kind of it's kind of a unique array into the
franchise it's sort of like the opposite of what
happened with Thor which was a lot more heavy and
gravitas that became a joke this was like more
jokey and then now it's become like this heavy
bigger serious epic and it's pretty cool to see
how it's it's naturally got in there and still
feels like it and and it does worry about the
characters and I'm excited for Cassie Lang because
it seemed like yeah this would be the heart of
the movie is how much he wants time back you
would be willing to work with King and make such
a Desperate Measures call yeah for something that
is clearly not the smart move because it's preying
on some so Primal for him and it would be this the
selfish choice that you would be so tempted
to make yeah yeah man Hero's making selfish
choices that is a big part of MCU characters damn
you Star-Lord we could have gotten rid of Thanos
sooner I'm still mad about it that's all you had
to do never got over it guys are you excited for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania do you already
have your tickets what are you hoping happens
in the end did you read the script leaked I
haven't read it yet it's kind of hard to find now
Luis gonna be in it that's all I want to know
that's all I want to know tell me all right guys
we got ourselves a new Patron his name is Garth
Garth ooh Garth McMurray party on Garth you're
gonna get a traditional shout out in the form of
G stands for G willikers Dre only bad syllables
ah a stands for ant Ant-Man cause you're on
the Ant-Man video R stands for rodeo clowns
are disturbing T stands for you are titanium H
stands for Heathen yeah yeah you filthy you're
a heathen Garth yeah anyway Garth I hope we uh
nailed the shout out in the way that you were
hoping to I think we did a little bit more
than we were required for out of the park
into the next County I'm happy that we were
able to fulfill our duties our obligations in
order to make you a happy camper and making
you a happy camper just makes me a mediocre
camper so thank you Garth for being part of a
patreon page and showing the support you have
graduated from a citizen of the reject Nation to
a super sexy citizen region there's a lot of work